that's my father the man beside him is
Howland Reed Mira's father you're
leaving I don't want to leave you but
when when they come I need to be with my
family you're safe safe as anyone can be
now you don't need me anymore no I don't
hey everybody so I've gotten a lot of
requests to do videos for Howland and
Meera Reed because obviously we know
that Jojen is dead but Meera Reed is a
fairly big character in the story right
now in Howland Reed is just another big
character that the show has chosen not
to do so far there's a lot of theories
about what they might include in season
8 but if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're doing Game of Thrones
till season 8 gets here obviously
there'll be a bunch of book stuff once
it drops and there is a giveaway that
I'll explain at the end of the video the
first rule of tower of joy Club is that
you do not talk about Tower of joy so
really we only know of Howland Reed what
we saw in the flashbacks in what Meera
has said part of the reason for that big
long scene in episode 4 of season 7 was
sort of mirrors goodbye on the TV show
there's like the theory that she could
show up again during season 8 but Ellie
Kendrick the actress has booked a couple
jobs for projects that are dropping in
2018 meaning that she'll be filming
those while they're filming Game of
Thrones season 8 so usually my policy is
to Never Say Never but it does look like
there's a very strong possibility that
we'll never see her again on the TV show
in some of the dialogue during that
scene like you don't need me anymore no
I don't need you anymore brand being
such a huge huge dick to her was a way
for the show to tell you in no uncertain
terms that they really didn't need her
anymore and she was just going off to
greywater watch down in the south to be
with her family
the only Howland Reed in present-day
that we've gotten so far has been
anecdotally through Meera and Jojen when
they first met up with bran and OSHA and
tried to explain who they were and why
they had shown up
Jojen had been having the visions Meera
was his protector so she was just sort
of along for the ride
my brother so I'm gonna help him fulfill
this thing that he says needs to happen
but that's really about it during the
course of events in season 1 when Robb
Stark finds out what happens to Ned and
calls his Bannerman in the war of the
five kings starts heating up he sends
word down to Howland Reed in the neck
saying dis plead any Lannisters Drive
that try to make it north up to
Winterfell
so in the flashback once they defeat
Arthur Dayne here in Ned Stark runs up
and learns about what's going on with
Jon Snow and Lyanna Rhaegar Targaryen
you see Howland Reed in the background
here picking over the bodies trying to
see if anybody is still alive
they took the baby Arthur Dayne sword
because Ned was an honorable man took
the sword back to Starfall to ashara
dayne there are a lot of conspiracy
theories about ashara dayne especially
before they revealed the full truth of
the tower of joy because she said to
have thrown herself off the battlements
of Starfall at their castle after Ned
Stark told her what happened but it's
always possible that he revealed the
full truth and then she just pretended
to die so that she could hide out so
that nobody would try to get it out of
her because she was the lady-in-waiting
- Elia Martell
so most of her friends and the people
that she served had just died so it's
always possible that in her grief she
did kill herself I don't think there was
any foul play involved in her death but
then Ned Stark just returned back to
Winterfell Howland Reed peeled off when
they got to the neck he went back to
greywater watch assumed his seat in his
duties of just making sure that the area
was secure had a family you have Jojen
and Meera Reed they come along later and
that's really all that Martin says about
him until you get to the war of the five
kings where he's just basically
patrolling the neck but I think part of
the idea is is that they went back north
he probably had suspicions about what
Ned Stark saw in the Tower of joy he
probably didn't reveal anything official
about Rhaegar Targaryen he wasn't
discreet said this is exactly what my
sister Lyanna told me this is the
promise she extracted from me Helen Reed
probably made some guesses about what he
saw up there when he saw the baby come
down oh that baby is probably Rhaegar
Targaryen but I think it's safe to
assume that Ned Stark extracted a
promise of silence from him like he
ordered him to go to the neck and just
hang out there tell no one of what
happened here we will never speak of it
again
and
sure enough he never spoke of it even to
Catelyn Stark she said that any time
that she would bring the matter up he
said that he would not speak of it so
you have to imagine 15 16 years go by
they have Robb Stark Jon Snow the rest
of their children he still refuses to
talk of it to present day which is why
she treats Jon Snow so badly because she
just assumes that he's a bastard he came
back from the war of rebellion with this
babe
so she naturally just put two and two
together the way that anybody would you
come back with a baby oh this is
probably a bastard that you had while
you were at war but until we learned we
were getting the brand flashbacks a lot
of people just felt like Howland Reed
was the ace in the hole oh he's the guy
that can show up and tell us what's
going on but I think the TV opted for
the more spectacular visual reveal
because there are a couple things that
they've changed from the way brands
weirwood site works in the books so they
can see anywhere the faces of the
weirwood czar so if there were a
weirwood at the Tower of joy then he
could totally flash back in the books so
the cool thing about the books is that
we don't know exactly how George R
Martin is going to make that Tower of
joy reveal only that the reveal is salt
like Jon Snow is the son of Rhaegar and
Lyanna so we know what the end goal is
going to be but we just don't know how
he's going to accomplish that Helen Reid
could be a part of that reveal but even
in the books Howland Reed is such a
minor character and has been so absent
from the action that it makes sense that
if Martin were going to use him for a
big Tower of joy reveal he would have
started the process of setting that up a
little bit more in most of what we
learned about Rhaegar has come through
Barristan Selmy in maester aemon maester
aemon did spend a lot of time when he
was up at the wall corresponding with
Rhaegar during his lifetime
so during his final years they talked a
lot about dragons about prophecies so I
have a feeling part of the reveal in the
books will be made the way they did it
on the TV show in some documents that
people find documents of maester aemon
that are hidden somewhere documents at
the Citadel but for now even though you
would think that Howland Reed is a
relatively important character because
of what he saw it seems like his
greatest importance has been in giving
birth to Meera and Jojen Reed who played
a much more important part in the story
getting Brant up to the three-eyed Raven
so obviously the winds of winter book
hasn't dropped yet so Meera Reed is
still
beneath the three-eyed Ravens weirwood
with bran up north of the wall but
there's a lot of big questions about her
continued importance in the books
because even though you have the army of
the Dead there is no night king that
George R Martin has written about in
present day but there is a solid chance
that things go down the way they went
down in the TV show in the army of the
Dead makes their way through the
enchantment and they kill the three-eyed
Raven and Brandt has to escape with Mira
because you have to remember that Martin
revealed how Hodor got his name and he
got it holding the door as they were
leaving the weirwood to escape the army
of the dead so that just implies that
that event will also happen in the books
but I think because Martin doesn't have
a camera to worry about and like actual
physical actors Mira will stick around
if they do go back to Winterfell
eventually because they leave the where
would you assume that events play out in
a relatively similar way like they make
their way back down south to explain
what's going on to everyone the army of
the Dead is coming this is what we need
to do to prepare so the funny thing is
that for as different as the TV show has
become from the books there are a couple
of big events that seem like they're
gonna play out in a similar way even
though the characters that you see at
those places are gonna be different so I
think in the books Mira does stick
around because she's one of the
strongest characters they've introduced
and she and brand have grown closer and
I think that they made brand more of a
dick on the TV show to make that break
between the two of them feel a little
bit stronger like oh now she definitely
has a reason to go but by all accounts
it does look like they're never coming
back on the TV show now I mean it's
always possible that they could work
them in for a day for a couple cameos
the sand snakes said that during season
seven because they wanted to kill them
off in that big scene they asked them to
come back but it was really short notice
Jessica Henrik who plays Nymeria sand
that she was busy shooting the iron fist
and defender's TV shows and they
basically called her like a couple weeks
before she was getting ready to film and
said hey do you want to come do this we
need you for a couple scenes if you
don't show up people will wonder what
happened to your character we won't be
able to explain that but it seems like
this is that version of that scene for
Mira's character so I know it makes it
seem like Howland Reed is kind of a dick
for not showing up and explaining to
everyone but I think that's mostly out
of loyalty to Ned Stark in the promise
that he made
but if he is mentioned during winds of
winter then we could talk a little bit
more about him because they still have
to make the Tower of joy reveal so
eventually he'll be mentioned one way or
another whether it's in flashback or in
someone's memory or in a scroll so let
me know in the comments given all the
evidence you've seen so far do you think
the TV show ever mentions Howland or
mirror Reed again even just mentions
them forget bringing them on the show
off chance somebody mentions house Reed
when they're talking about all the
forces they have available to them when
they talk about their Bannerman there's
a new round of the book giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from last
week moonlight please private message me
so I can get your contact details you
can click here for all my for ragnarok
Easter eggs and you can click here to
learn all about the Targaryen prequel
story thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight